[MUSIC]
Hello, I'm Mariese from Belgium.
>> My name is Maria but
you can call me Goodie.
>> Hi everyone.
>> Hi, I'm originally from India and
also grew up in China and Dallas, Texas.
>> But actually spent most of my life
growing up here in beautiful Guatemala.
>> My name is Yasu,
I'm originally from Kobe, Japan,
the home of your favorite kobe beef.
>> Hi, my name is and
I'm from Mumbai, India.
>> Hi everyone, I'm Smina from New York.
>> Hey everyone my name is and
I'm from Manila, Philippines.
>> Hey guys, this is from Paris.
>> Hi, I'm Marco from St.
Petersburg, Russia.
>> I'm speaking to you from beautiful
Badlands National Park South Dakota.
And I just want to say, I can't wait to
meet everybody and get started at the GSB.
>> Hi, my name is Maria and
I hail from Uppsala, Sweden.
I used to be a concert pianist.
>> A quick fun fact about me is that I've
met the Queen of England, somehow, twice.
>> I'm literally moving to
the other side of the world.
So this feels incredibly exciting,
and yet absolutely terrifying.
>> One fun fact about me is that I grew
up in the town where the gummy bear was
invented.
>> After third grade,
I never missed a day of school.
>> I've spent the last five years
living in Miami working for
the parent company of Burger King.
Despite this,
I have never actually tried a whopper.
>> I actually got my pilot's
license before my driver's license.
>> I absolutely love electric vehicles and
I want to work in that space,
but I just can't drive.
>> Fun fact,
I'm the proud father of 13 houseplants.
>> And former intelligence officer and
investigative journalist.
>> One fun fact about me is that,
as a modern dancer,
the way that I prepare myself for
presentation is by doing handstands
somewhere where no one can see me.
>> I make wine and continue 8,000 years
of wine-making tradition in Georgia.
>> One fun fact about me is that I'm
extremely passionate about travel.
I'm currently visiting my 45th
country in the Dominican Republic.
>> Fun fact about me is that I
actually make YouTube videos.
>> I was on Jeopardy in 2012 and
I got to talk to Alex Trebek in
a Sean Connery voice and he loved it.
>> I am convinced that I made the best
quarantine banana bread of anybody I know.
>> What I'm most excited about is getting
to meet you all over the course of
the next couple of weeks.
In terms of advice that I would share,
my neighbors.
[LAUGH]
>> I'm most excited to meet all of you and
learn about all the different backgrounds
and passion we have in our class.
>> To learn from you all to grow
is hopefully more than just
a professional or a leader,
but to grow as a person.
>> Feels like it's been so
long and the time is finally here.
So, I can't wait to meet you all soon.
>> And what I'm most excited about is,
of course,
meeting all the fantastic people that are
going to be sharing this journey together.
>> And one piece of advice that I would
like to give to my fellow classmates is to
just be your most true, authentic self.
>> If I were looking back
at this at graduation,
I hope that by now we've discovered our
passions, made lifelong friends, and
come out stronger and happier.
>> The best years of our
lives are ahead of us.
Please savor every moment of it.
>> Let's stay optimistic, take risks, and
build the dreams that brought us here.
>> Woohoo MBA Class of 2023,
congratulations, everyone.
>> Let's make the most out of it.
Let's have all of those heated intense
discussions on all of those ideas that
may actually change lives, change
organizations, and change the world.
[MUSIC]